okay everybody I have the lead actor of
jigsaw matt passmore joining me today
and he plays Logan Nelson and Matt I
wanted to ask you to start off Logan
Nelson can you give us a little insight
of what who this character is because
from the trailers it looks like he's a
doctor of some sort well he's uh he's
he's a karna he's a chief medical
examiner for his district so detectives
come to him because the bodies come to
him on the table and he helps with the
forensics and tries to piece together
clues and help them try and catch this
guy for a role like this did you have to
audition or were you offered this role
how did that go about you know I I put
him addition down and then the producers
wanted to meet over lunch and when we
met I hadn't read it yet so they were
like okay well you need to read it
because you know what's the plan talking
and turns out that they were big fans of
a show I did over here and yeah then
when I read it I went oh crap this
thing's this thing's awesome twists you
know it's bringing all the fun back to
soar and and so yeah from there they
were pretty keen from the word go so I
was I was blessed with an even the ride
and easy riding to this one yeah that's
that's really cool and I mean when you
read the script was there a point
because we know the Saw movies can get
like really gory and twisted did you say
to yourself one point though like what
am I getting into like are they gonna
put me in traffic did that kind of your
head well you know it's um I was told
this by a mate well it's really after I
started shooting which is good because
it's pretty intimidating but it's the
most it's in the Guinness Book of
Records as the most successful horror
franchise of all time so you know that's
intimidating guys and don't screw it up
and yeah it says if there's also a
family of people in sword those people
have been doing you know all seven along
the way so you really kind of jump into
the family that is sore and straight
away I bring the script I thought oh
this is really harkening back to the
first one this is it's not about the
gore and it's not about the grotesque
traps in this one it goes back to that
psychological the psychological choices
that the first film really could really
put people into and I really I really
like that I thought okay this is this is
getting back to its roots which I
thought was perfect that's really
exciting to hear because I'm a huge fan
and most of our the first song movie it
is my favorite saw and going back to
you're just saying about feeling that
like okay pressure of like this is a
huge horror franchise so since the last
couple Saw movies before this didn't do
so great with the critics did you feel
that pressure as well like okay I got to
perform this has to be good we are this
franchise needs a hit like you feel that
pressure one set yeah it was it's a good
pressure to because the stearic brothers
and I were able to really walk this fine
line in anything we were doing so we
would we would discuss this the tone of
what we were doing and just making sure
we really got it right so that you know
the audience didn't felt
feel like they were being cheated or you
know there's it is quite easy to cheat
in a in a horror film and then go like
oh this person did um so I think the
thing that's always been great about saw
along with the the psychological testing
that goes on and you know John Kramer
trying to get people to appreciate life
again is there's this Cluedo element and
the twists I like you know did you pick
it did you pick who was the who is going
to be the killer all that sort of stuff
so yeah I think it's definitely gone
from the gore back to the fun that's
really exciting so you think it kind of
fits more into a psychological thriller
effect again yeah yeah that's right and
you know the I mean there's still lots
of fun and blood in this one but it's
you know it's that that terror of
putting yourself in those people's shoes
where they have to make a choice is is
definitely back rather than just let's
watch bodies get slice and dice right so
for a role like this where you're
playing someone in the medical field and
you're going to be in horror situations
did you have to do like a lot of
research to prepare for it like okay do
I gotta know exactly what I'm talking
about like how did that kind of go about
like how'd you prepare
I've done I've done a few cop shows
before and you know there's always a
chief medical examiner role in a few
other side I didn't exactly go and you
know live with the medical examiner
before this right but I certainly had a
general idea as to what they do
we had a um we had an adviser on set for
all of the scenes that were in the
coroner coroner's office so there was
someone there really guiding me clear
okay this Joey this is how we first
approached your body this is what we do
with the organs all that sort of stuff
and and then you know Logan is
ex-military and we find out that he was
met it can Iraq in the Battle of
Fallujah okay being ex-military myself I
really liked that backstory and and the
PTSD that he still seems to be
struggling with his demons and yeah
because he was he was captured and
tortured we find out a little so you
know you're talking about someone who
brings demons about being tortured and
into someone who's being swept up in the
web of John Kramer right so you so you
being ex-military and then your
character having that route in there so
when you were doing certain scenes could
you tap maybe into your psychology of
what it was like in the military to get
in the character for this role in that
specific situation yeah I could tap into
what it was like to be in the military I
mean the most dangerous place I ever
went when I was in the Army was Kings
Cross did me at night so you know we
would just get into trouble so I I
certainly never saw a combat service or
anything like that and never would I
proposed to know what that actually
feels like but you know someone who has
served in one of the detectives we find
out was served with him so it's that
really nice connection there of
brotherhood and you know as everyone
starts to start to suspect each other
that little bond between these
characters is interesting to play I like
that a lot that that makes me very
excited about it already just hearing
these little tidbits and we see in the
trailer and then the poster they just
released for jigsaw where your character
we see is in some sort of like laser
trap it looks likes over your head
now can you go into like how how do you
get into that intensive a scene when
you're acting and was that like actual
laser that was around your like how did
that scene go well no they couldn't
actually use like you know cutting
lasers around my neck that that would
have been a little too unsafe although I
was in Toronto so you know anything
could happen but yeah no it was the the
traps also seem to be evolving as well
like this is so for 2017 you know it's
not a complete reboot which I really
liked it takes into account the Canon of
everything that's gone before it but it
is it does have this this fresh breeze
and this fresh energy put into this
world and we start to see that with the
traps as well that you know they're
moving that old rustic you know rusty
blades type out or the you know the
roasting mechanics type traps into
something that's definitely a little
more modern and you know nowhere do we
see that more than the laser trap right
so I was an s2 or on the topic of traps
I saw on your Instagram that you had
tried on the reverse bear trap classic
iconic trap when you put that on yeah
that thing is no joke yeah is it real
like could you hurt yourself with that
thing on no it's not it's not set you
know whatever Springs and mechanisms are
there they definitely make sure those
things aren't set just so that an idiot
like myself he's introducing around on
set going home I better and you know my
face just splits in half so you know I
think they they made it safer for idiots
like me I think we made it
childproof that's hysterical now also I
love your instagrams you post a lot of
funny stuff from set and I thought it
was really funny the picture had in the
trailer with Billy the puppet now did
you get like starstruck around it was
that the actual ability the puppet they
used in the movie yeah and it was it was
really funny it was one of my first
weeks shooting and I go into the makeup
and hair trailer and there's Billy there
getting his hair done and you know he's
got six people around him there's only
one person working on me and she was
bored and it's just six people
Billy the puppet okay we know who the
star is
but yeah you know I almost pictured him
whispering in my ear like don't screw
this up man
do not screw up my man it's great
meeting you know one of those icons yeah
and yeah and he's when you start getting
into those eyes it's it's kind of creepy
oh sure
definitely and on that topic to have had
you seen all the song movies before you
got the role and if not did you have to
watch them like did you binge them at
once you knew you were in this you know
I've seen the first one but I haven't
seen any other so when we when we first
started but the others were very much
the directors well you know at sea one
two and three that's definitely this
harkening of time that we want to go
back to and and it's definitely
necessary to have or for me it was
necessary to have information about what
had happened after that but we were
talking totally in and you know what the
fine line of tone that we wanted to find
at this they say listen just just what's
the first three and and we'll take it
from there because I think this will
this jigsaw really grabs you know those
fanboys and the people that were on the
annual tradition it's Halloween let's go
to saw and then I think it's it's not
necessary to know the whole canon so
that Lionsgate I think we're very
adamant about that so they can so there
can be a whole fresh new audience that
doesn't have to go back and watch seven
saws in order to enjoy this one right
right so that that's very smart that
they went that way and uh do you feel
like having the I saw you guys read the
premiere last night and then you have
pictures of like billboards of jigsaw
out there is it is surreal feeling to be
like I'm a lead in this huge horror
movie coming out I kind of car franchise
this weekend like what are you what's
going on to your head right now do you
feel like this like kind of like
butterflies or no you know what it's
cool I mean my mom's upset she doesn't
I'm not in her good moments horror films
do a film with him but yeah you know
just the other day I saw the billboard
of saw
directly over my favorite sports bar
here in Los Angeles that's a sign I
think it's time to doctor sign right
over my favorite sports bar you know
it's very cool and the premier you know
Lionsgate have gone all out so it's
really nice to feel like they are behind
it 100% and they are you know they are
very happy and when you know when a
studio is really happy with something
they let you know and they're pouring
money into the publicity and they have
really really high hopes of this thing
and I guess so the continuation on from
here as well I think they really want to
bring back that tradition of hey it's
Halloween the weekend before go to saw
right brilliant marketing brilliant
brilliant and definitely hits that
audience you know and I would say I'm
one of those soft fanboys is to and I'm
I guess secondly a Halloween obsessor so
this is just that season for it it fits
perfect now you don't have to answer
this question because you don't any
spoilers but I have to ask is there a
chance we're gonna hear that iconic
twist music from all the song movies
past in this movie are we going to hear
that
you are definitely going to hear that
they have gone back with the the same
composer that composed music for all of
them and there are some different music
in this as you know there is a different
kind of fresh tone but that theme is
absolutely there and that and it really
kicks in and some you know big climactic
moments so great you know it got a when
that really kicked in at a certain point
last night because audience is clapping
and cheering and stuff like that so yeah
it's giving you it's giving you more for
what you know and also a fresh new fun
rollercoaster to go on excellent that
gets me so excited everyone listening
all my star fans go see jigsaw opening
this weekend it's a perfect Halloween
movie to take a date a friend go by
yourself if you want Matt thank you so
much for joining me is there anything
else you wanted to promote or anything
else you want to say before we
disconnect no I just take your adult
incontinence pads and fill them up when
you're in there cuz you'll get your ID
on there we go awesome well Matt thank
you so much for joining me I hope to
talk to you again soon and I can't wait
to see the movie see you tonight
Thanks